we have a very famous example a video
that's gone viral on Twitter
13 year old girl says to Warren Buffett
I'm really worried about the U.S dollar
as the reserve currency of the world
we're printing lots and lots of dollars
and if we're not the reserve currency
the value of the dollar is going to
collapse we're going to have
hyperinflation what should I do Mr
Buffett
you know and I I wouldn't normally
criticize you know a
respected successful business person of
his age but he and Charlie Munger did
choose to go up on stage and answer
questions and give Financial guidance
and advice and investment advice and
they are looked up to and so you watch
Warren Buffett answer the question and
his answer is
well yeah I mean I guess the FED
inflated the money but they needed to
and uh you know it's really difficult
you know in politics of difficult
problem and yeah you're right it is a
problem and Monger will say you know the
Dollar's going to zero it's going to
zero they know it's a problem
and then he kind of meanders through it
with a with a an end advice which is
well you know I don't know but you know
America is a great country
dump out against America
but the ant but the but the the blood
curdling terrifying you know depressing
you know take away from the Clippers is
the 13 year old girl knows what the
problem is the country's full of people
that can articulate the problem and
write thousand page books on the problem
if you're rich
in America you don't have the answer
because you're too comfortable
right and so what you've got is a bunch
of of Mega billionaires that are very
successful in America but they don't
have an answer or solution to the 13
year old girl the solution to that
question was Bitcoin right and Warren
Buffett and Charlie Munger can't allow
themselves to understand that because
because they're so successful they don't
need to open their mind to and embrace a
new idea
if Warren Buffett woke up tomorrow and
his bank seized all of his assets and
they were devalued to zero
and he was a pauper
and his neighbor the Uber driver was
walking around with a hundred thousand
dollars worth of bitcoin on a hardware
wallet Warren would say what is that
again explain that to me yeah what do
you mean my government my bank can't
steal all my money that's a pretty good
idea
right and and so I I think that when
you're a refugee from fleeing Iraq or
you're crossing the border
and you know and when you try to go
through an airport and a hostile regime
steals all your money and seizes all
your gold when you have to flee your
Thousand Acre or ten Thousand Acre Farm
in Africa because a hostile regime
decided it was illegal for people like
you to own land
when that happens you become a believer
in a a non-sovereign store of value
crypto asset Network which is what
Bitcoin is
the people that came to this country the
huguenots you know the the settlers the
the colonists I think they understood it
I mean they had all their all their
property seized from them from wherever
they came from and their idea was here's
a place where I can own something and
people might not steal it from me
as soon as they got here people started
trying to steal it from them again right
that's the Human Condition just slower
just slower but that's why they kept
going west it's like I gotta go west
where there's no politicians
to steal it from me right and that and
that's a pretty powerful driver
so I think that that the conclusion is
people that are comfortable they're fat
dumb and happy in the United States are
going to continue to reject new ideas
like crypto assets like Bitcoin because
they don't have to
if I don't have to embrace a new idea
when I get to a certain age I won't and
that that is
that is as old as the it's the the
Thomas Kuhn structure of Scientific
Revolution he said
Paradigm shifts only get embraced in
times of War
or when the Old Guard dies
if you want to introduce a new idea you
need a war
Wars kind of work because if we're
fighting a war and I introduce an
airplane and I drop a nuclear bomb on
your head then you stop rejecting air
power and you stop rejecting Atomic
weapons you embrace the reality that
yeah they do work and maybe you need to
figure it out Wars work but absent a war
people just have to you know they just
have to pass on because they're not
going to embrace a new idea so you
talked about Charlie Munger and Charlie
Munger gave the famous rat poison speech
right they actually gave two speeches
and the second one he said no I didn't
say it was poison I said it was rat
poison so
you're saying that he's in the middle of
the of the system was he disingenuous
was he dishonest or was he mistaken
if you don't
first you have to have an open mind and
say is it possible that this works
and then second you have to spend
somewhere around 10 hours to understand
it I just don't think he has an open
minded I don't think he spent 10 hours
right I mean it's not it's not uncommon
right people in their 80s and their 90s
don't generally embrace the wonder that
is the Unreal Engine or Tick-Tock
90s right so it's I I wouldn't again if
they were private citizens I don't I
don't criticize private 80 and 90 year
olds octogenarians and and the like for
not embracing the new cool thing right
they don't have to like this you don't
have to like drone races you know you
know my my father doesn't have to like
drone races in his 80s that's fine
but the point is if you're going to tell
people how to invest hundreds of
billions of dollars or trillions of
dollars and you're going to give advice
to a 13 year old about how she can not
be poor or not or not starve to death
I I think that then you have to actually
study these things and the elephant in
the room is everybody in the world is
facing inflation everyone in the world
is facing counterparty risk everyone
everywhere in the world we're losing
faith in governments Banks and
currencies
the solution is a bank that isn't run by
people that isn't subject to the whim of
a government
that is Incorruptible that allows you to
be your own bank right and that is a
message that's getting out we just need
to keep beating the drum on that it is I
think the most important Economic
Opportunity slash issue slash technology
of our time so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you
foreign